لقد شاهد ملايين الأشخاص الآن هذه
الصورة وهي تلتقط طبيبًا
يريح مريضًا مسنًا في
يوم عيد الشكر الذي
انضم إلينا الآن هو أن الطبيب الدكتور جوزيف
فارون هو رئيس الأركان في
المركز الطبي التذكاري الموحد في
هيوستن دكتور فارون كما هو الحال دائمًا شكرًا جزيلاً
لك لكونك  معنا ، نشكرك على
تعاطفك ، المصور الذي التقط
تلك الصورة كان يذهب ناكامورا من الصور الجميلة ،
يجب أن نقول
أنك كنت الطبيب ، أخبرنا بما
يحدث هناك ،
نعم ، ما الذي يحدث هو أنك تعرف كما
تعلم أنني كنت شديد الشفافية مع
وسائل الإعلام  لذلك ، عادةً ما يكون لدي وسائط في
وحدتنا حتى يتمكن الناس من رؤية ما يحدث ،
لذا
فإنني أتتبع المصور ،
وأثناء ذهابي إلى وحدة كوبي الخاصة بي ، أرى
أن
هذا المريض المسن خارج سريره
ويحاول الخروج من  من الغرفة
وهو يبكي ،
لذا اقتربت منه وأخبرته
لماذا تبكين ويقول الرجل
إنني أريد أن أكون مع زوجتي
حتى تعرف أنني أمسك به أنا فقط أحمله
لم أكن أعرف أنني كنت
تم تصويره في ذلك الوقت
أه وأنت تعلم أنه كان يبكي فقط وفي
النهاية
شعر بتحسن وتوقف عن
البكاء أريد أن أكون مع زوجتي قال
بالطبع هل
يمكن أن يكون مع زوجته الآن من
يمكنه رؤيته
في المحترف  في الوقت الحالي لا
يمكنك أن تعرف أننا بحاجة إلى
إكمال علاجه ، يجب أن يكون
سلبيًا أه عند المبادلة حتى نتمكن
بعد ذلك من إرساله أه خارج المستشفى
ولكن أه من الصعب جدًا أن
تتخيل أنك داخل  غرفة
يأتي فيها الناس ببدلات فضائية
وليس لديك اتصال مع أي شخص آخر
أو عبر الهاتف إذا كنت محظوظًا ،
أعني أنها صعبة للغاية وعندما
تكون فردًا مسنًا
يكون الأمر أكثر صعوبة لأنك
تشعر أنك كذلك  بمفردك ،
تشعر بالعزلة ، لقد ذكرت بذلة الفضاء للتو ،
أعني أن هذا ما هو ملحوظ جدًا في تلك
الصورة ، فأنت تعلم أنه المريض
بوضوح وكنت ترتدي
كل هذه الملابس الواقية ، فما الذي كان
يدور في رأسك
خلال هذا المنزل ، لقد كنت أشعر كثيرًا
آسف جدًا له ، أعني أنني كنت أشعر
بالحزن مثله تمامًا وكنت
أتذكر
جميع المرضى الذين اضطررت إلى القيام
بأشياء مماثلة معك أعلم
أنني سأذهب إلى الغرف سأجلس
في السرير وأتحدث معهم
لأنني  إنهم يحتاجون حقًا إلى شخص ما
ليساعدهم ، وطاقم العمل الخاص بي جيد جدًا في
القيام بذلك ،
لكن أه لدينا الكثير من المرضى لدرجة
أننا لا نستطيع أحيانًا
أن نحمل كل مريض أو يمسك
بيد مريض أو على الأقل
نحاول أن نكون أكثر من ذلك بقليل  بشر ما الذي يمكن
أن تخبرنا به عن
أداء
هذا المريض هذا الصباح ، إنه في الواقع يقوم بعمل رائع ،
إنه
أفضل حالًا أه نحن نأمل أنه
قبل نهاية الأسبوع سيتمكن
من الخروج من المستشفى ،
هذه أخبار رائعة كيف  غالبًا ما
يحدث هذا ،
غالبًا ما أعني أن الناس هم فقط
المرضى الذين
يشعرون بالحزن الشديد ، والبعض منهم يبكون ، والبعض منهم
يحاول الهروب ،
لقد كان لدينا في الواقع شخص ما حاول
الهروب إلى النافذة في اليوم الآخر ،
آه ، لقد أصبحوا منعزلين للغاية.
حقا تريد الخروج
هو عليه  ضعيف للغاية ، ما
مدى تعقيد
تلقيح الملايين من العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
وموظفي الدعم
، وكم من الوقت
تتوقع أن يستغرق ذلك ،
أعني أننا سأقول إن
الجميع يعمل بجد حقًا للإشارة إلى
نوع ما
سلسلة التوزيع لإيصالها
إلى العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية ،
إنه أمر معقد لا توجد طريقة
للتغلب عليه ، أعني حتى لو قلت
إننا نركز على مجموعات منفصلة معينة
سيتجاوز هذا العدد العرض في
المرحلة الأولى من توزيع اللقاح
وسيكون لدينا  لاتخاذ بعض
القرارات الصعبة بشأن التوزيع الفني في
كل موقع لمن يحصل عليه أولاً
، والشيء الآخر هو أننا يجب أن نعمل
بالتوازي لزيادة قبول اللقاح الذي
نشهده في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
وحتى بين العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية ، هناك
بعض التردد الحقيقي في  قبول
اللقاح حتى لو كان
أمامك مباشرةً ، لذا فإن التوزيع يمثل نصف
اللغز
ثم التأكد من أننا نقوم
بالكثير من التثقيف
والرسائل العامة لجعل  تأكد
من استلامه بمجرد وصوله إلى المكان الذي
يحتاج إلى الذهاب إليه ،
نعم إلى تلك النقطة ، كنت تقول إنك
تعلم حتى عندما يصبح اللقاح
متاحًا
، تُظهر استطلاعات الرأي أن أجزاء كبيرة من
الجمهور الأمريكي تقول
انظر لن أحصل على اللقاح
وأظهر استطلاع أكسيوس إيبسوس هذا الأسبوع أن
51 في المائة فقط من الأمريكيين كانوا مستعدين
للتحصين عندما يصبح اللقاح متاحًا لأول مرة
، وقال 48 كاملًا إنهم لن
يحصلوا على التطعيم هناك على الرغم من وجود الكثير
من بيانات السلامة ،
كيف يمكنك أن تريح  المتشككون ، دكتور
تشو وأنا أعني كم من السكان
سيحتاجون بالفعل
للتطعيم حتى يعمل ، نحن
بحاجة حقًا إلى فهم
المخاوف التي يمكنني تخمينها ،
أعني أننا أطلقنا على جهود اللقاح
سرعة الالتواء التشغيلية التي تعلمناها
باستخدام مصطلحات مثل ترخيص الاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ ،
تنقل هذه المصطلحات حقًا التسرع في
الأمان وأعتقد أن ما نحتاج إليه حقًا
هو مشاركة الكثير حول ما نعرفه عن
هذه العملية بقدر ما نستطيع
لقد تم القيام به بصرامة كبيرة من قبل
أشخاص يعرفون ما
يفعلونه ببيانات السلامة حتى في مجموعات من
كبار السن
وأولئك الذين يعانون من أمراض مصاحبة
كانت مطمئنة
للغاية ولذا أعتقد أن جزءًا منها هو جزء من
التواصل
ولكني أعتقد أيضًا أننا  بحاجة إلى القيام بالكثير من
العمل في المجتمعات
لسماع المزيد من الأشخاص حول
سبب ترددهم
الشديد وما الذي قد يغير الأشياء بالنسبة لهم ، لذلك
أعتقد
مرة أخرى أن هذا العمل مهم جدًا
ويجب أن يحدث بالتوازي
مع جهود التوزيع التي
أريدها  للتحدث إليكم مع شخص ما
فعل
ذلك بالطريقة الصحيحة ، حسنًا الآن كان الحدث
ضخمًا للاحتفال بعيد الميلاد التاسع والتسعين
الشهر الماضي لوالده ، حسنًا ، أعني
كم
منا ينعم بوجود أحد
أفراد عائلتنا ، ناهيك عن أحد والدينا.
أريد إحضار لاري غولدستيكر
بلانو تكساس الذي ينضم إلي الآن ،
تهانينا لوالدك ، شكرًا
لك على الانضمام إلي
الآن ، لاري ، أريد العودة إلى هذا
الموقف الآن عندما تقول
إننا حاولنا القيام بذلك بالطريقة الصحيحة ماذا
فعلت  أنت تفعل فقط حتى يتمكن الناس من فهم
المربعات التي حددتها حتى
عيد ميلاده في أكتوبر ، بدأنا
الحديث هذا الصيف وحتى
أجرينا المحادثة ، هل نذهب أم
لا وقررنا أننا سنذهب إلى
كل شخص في الحجر الصحي
لمدة أسبوعين قبل ذلك ، أم أخي
الموجود في  تم بالفعل اختبار سان فرانسيسكو وزوجته
مسبقًا ، لقد قمت بقيادة
السيارة بدلاً من الطيران لمدة 10 ساعات بدلاً
من السفر بالطائرة
لنكون آمنين ، ارتدى الجميع قناعًا
وفعلنا كل ما اعتقدنا أنه من
المفترض أن نفعله حتى وصلنا إلى هناك
وبعد ذلك بمجرد وصولنا إلى هناك بقينا
نحن الاثني عشر منا ، سواء في
منزل والدي أو في منزل أخي ،
لم نرتدي الأقنعة عندما كنا معًا
في المرة الوحيدة التي
خرجنا فيها ليلة السبت لتناول عشاء عيد ميلاده ،
12 منا في غرفة خاصة فقط نحن
النوادل يدخلون ويخرجون
وفي نهاية عطلة نهاية الأسبوع يوم
الاثنين ،
بدأ الجميع في إظهار
أعراض الطمع ،
كم منكم أصيب بمرض
12 من أصل 12 كان هناك بالإضافة إلى أنني
أصبت زوجتي التي لم تكن تعاني  le
للانضمام إلينا
عندما عدت إلى هنا ، 13.
لقد فعلت كل ما يمكن أن يخطر
ببالك بخلاف إلغاء الحفلة
ومرض جميعكم حرفيًا الآن ،
والأهم من ذلك أن
أبي 99 حصل عليه ، هل هو بخير ،
إنه بخير أه هو  فقد بعض
الوزن
آه كل قوته لم تعد أه
لكنني أقول إنه ربما يكون 90 في المائة